as we grow up and get older our bodies
begin to change sometimes those changes
can be a bit uncomfortable or even
bizarre we feel strange pains in new
places we grow seemingly a foot in
height overnight hair sprouts up in new
places and falls out of other places
whether it's puberty or just the aging
process it seems like the human body
never runs out of ways to surprise us
but those surprises are completely
normal and to be expected as part of
being alive unless you're one particular
young man whose body changed overnight
into something unrecognizable and
entirely anomalous
that's when a very special individual
will be calling matt tara comes in matt
was an ordinary 24 year old man with
nothing particularly interesting about
him sure he was a nice guy he was smart
he was great at chess and video games
and had an impressive memory for science
trivia but there was nothing unusual
about him every day he would get up go
to work at a board game and comic book
store chat with his co-workers and make
a few sales head home make dinner relax
and go to bed ready to do it all again
the next day it wasn't a glamorous life
or that exciting but it was a pleasant
life and he was happy to live it one
night matt was having a difficult time
sleeping he was tossing and turning
waking up every few minutes to a dull
aching feeling in his stomach he didn't
feel feverish or sick and the pain
wasn't sharp or indicative of an
emergency so he shrugged it off as
indigestion and tried to get back to
sleep we've all been there right
eventually he nodded off all the way he
woke up the next morning blurry-eyed and
exhausted from the rough night but
feeling otherwise fine he climbed out of
bed stretched and headed to the bathroom
to brush his teeth there in the mirror
he saw something that made him think he
might still be dreaming he pinched
himself and found that he was indeed
awake while he was sleeping somehow his
body had changed into something
completely impossible where his stomach
had once been there was a blue green and
brown orb that reminded him of a
photograph he had once seen a picture of
earth taken aboard the international
space station after calling into work
and explaining in a stammering voice
that he would not be coming in that day
matt did the only thing he could think
of he went to the hospital of course the
doctors had no idea what to do with him
it wasn't like they could just take out
his appendix or give him an antibiotic
none of them had ever seen anything like
this before fortunately for him one
doctor knew a lot more than he was
letting on matt wouldn't be the first
human to develop bizarre anomalous
traits and then stagger into a nearby
hospital for treatment that's why the
scp foundation has agents embedded in
major hospitals all across the world and
one such doctor was the man treating
matt on the downside he wouldn't be
enjoying his freedom much longer on the
upside it cost a hell of a lot less than
a regular uninsured hospital visit so
the field agent called up his superiors
wiped matt's record from the hospital
and soon after a group of foundation
agents came to collect the confused
unfortunate host of what soon would be
known as
scp-007
scp-007 is found within an abdominal
cavity on the body of matt also referred
to as the subject just below his rib
cage where his stomach would be most of
his abdomen is completely missing
including the muscles skin and organs
that should ordinarily be necessary for
his survival however he does not appear
to experience any pain or even
discomfort from his condition
scp-007 itself is a spherical planet
composed of soil and water none of which
actually touches any part of his body
the planet resembles a miniature
duplicate of earth about 60 centimeters
in diameter with its own weather
patterns and gravitational pull neither
of which appear to have any effect on
the subject nor do they seem to be
affected by his movements or behavior
there are also a variety of tiny
organisms dwelling on the planet's
surface that cannot be seen with the
naked eye though it greatly resembles
earth there are some notable differences
obviously instead of floating in space
and revolving around the sun this planet
does not appear to have an orbit it is
uncertain where the organisms on the
planet get their light from though it
does not seem to be our sun since the
organisms have not shown any negative
effects from the lack of sunlight and
presence of artificial light in the
foundation's site there are continents
visible on the planet's surface
surrounded by its sea but they do not
resemble a continental alignment that
can be traced to any point in our
earth's history as far for the life on
the small planet the organisms
navigating the surface of the world
inside matt's abdomen there are dozens
of identifiable species that bear a
passing resemblance to creatures on
earth there are blue cow like livestock
species of bird that appear to have
scales red and orange trees and other
plant life and two intelligent species
that are notably and significantly
humanoid in appearance and behavior
observation of these intelligent species
via microscope and digital imaging has
revealed that they operate in societies
and are consistently developing and
improving their technology though their
technology was incredibly rudimentary
when matt was first brought into
containment resembling early nomadic
human civilizations it has progressed to
the level of 15th century humanity the
research team assigned to
scp-007 has noticed the recent
introduction of a version of the
printing press used to produce what
appear to be pamphlets and even entire
books the language these books are
printed in is unrecognizable and so the
contents of these materials are
currently unknown but the citizens of
the planet clearly have a grasp of the
written word and both the technology and
the desire to share it amongst
themselves
they have also developed an agricultural
system their farms have progressed to
the point of using new innovations such
as windmills used to mill grain
wheelbarrows used to transport crops and
other supplies and the practice of crop
rotation unfortunately with these
positive developments comes the ability
to escalate conflicts and wage wars they
look to have created parachutes
gunpowder and other explosives and their
own versions of the muzzle loaded rifle
however in spite of the ugliness of
battle there is beauty too the people of
the planet have created new ways to
express themselves with what can only be
described as new instruments closely
resembling the piano the mandolin and
the bagpipes as exciting and even moving
as it can be to watch these tiny beings
grow and change building their own
miniature society it is also a bit
troubling as these people continue to
progress at such a fast rate it stands
to reason that they will eventually
catch up to us or even surpass us in
terms of technology the research team
has not yet made any attempts to
communicate with the inhabitants of the
abdominal planet concerned about
influencing the developments of its
societies in any way or compromising
their ability to observe them without
interfering but they may not be able to
keep this up for much longer what will
happen if these tiny beings continue to
follow in our footsteps and create their
very own space programs if they leave
their planet's atmosphere they will
discover the truth that their world is
buried in the abdomen of what is to them
a giant man that reality would be enough
to shatter the sanity of many of us and
it would likely cause chaos on their
world there has been a great deal of
debate amongst the research team about
what to do if this should happen some
insist that the team should continue to
passively observe until the issue comes
up while others believe that they should
attempt to make contact with the
inhabitants of the planet in order to
soften the eventual blow to their
perceptions when they attempt space
exploration currently the debate rages
on as the research team keeps an eye on
the progression of the little
civilizations hopefully if they do
eventually make contact they will find a
way to make it clear that we come in
peace so who is matt tara the subject he
is a highly intelligent young man with a
shockingly casual attitude towards his
body's anomalous properties when asked
about the planet he simply says i just
woke up one day and there it was i don't
have any idea how it got there testing
revealed that he is genetically human
and there is nothing unusual or even
notable about the rest of his body he
provided his name willingly upon
arriving at the scp foundation but no
one of his name and age has ever lived
in his hometown area according to public
records to verify his identity he was
able to produce a social security card
and a driver's license which did not
appear to be forged or altered in any
way however when the numbers were run
through the system there was no match
officially this man does not exist it is
not entirely certain where he came from
or why there is no record of him but one
researcher posited that he somehow
crossed over from a parallel dimension
or that the presence of his abdominal
planet added as a kind of cognito
hazardous effect to him that erased all
perception of him from any records
whatever the case may be wherever he
came from he is here now because he has
not yet attempted escape or even shown a
desire to leave the foundation's site
there are no strict containment
procedures in place the only active
containment procedures for scp-007 are
for the subject's safety and security he
lives in a sealed room with furniture
and other items which are granted upon
request as long as they do not pose the
security risk the subject's room
includes an easy chair a bed a beanbag
chair a television with access to
several movie and television streaming
services a number of video game consoles
an espresso machine a microwave a
refrigerator an exercise bike and a
bookshelf filled with books and graphic
novels though he does not appear to
require food or water in order to
survive he enjoys consuming both food
and drinks and is especially fond of
coffee sodas grape juice sour cream and
onion potato chips mangoes and the
occasional treat of chinese takeout an
opinion which he shares with the
eccentric doctor clef the head
researcher assigned to scp-007 dr cho
has a weekly game of chess with matt
during which he evaluates the subject's
mental health and general emotional
well-being over the course of these
games the two have developed a friendly
relationship with each man winning about
half of the time matt asks about dr
cho's family and in return dr cho checks
in about his containment situation
seeing if there's anything the
foundation can provide to make his time
with them more comfortable most recently
matt requested a computer with an
internet connection mainly so that he
could play his video games in online
co-op mode but this request was denied
out of a concern that it would
compromise foundation security
sympathetic to his desire for company dr
cho has begun to allow the subject to
have visits with scp-507
who will stop by his containment
facility during his inactive periods for
a movie night or some video games matt
has described 507 as his best friend
aside from dr cho in spite of the
intricate world inexplicably floating in
his body the subject leads a relatively
simple life he does not seem to be
restless or resentful at all in fact he
seems largely content though his future
is uncertain and he is living through a
completely unprecedented anomalous
experience he is probably one of the
happiest anomalies contained at the scp
foundation and definitely one of the
most at peace with his anomalous status
whatever happens next for him he will
probably be ready for it with a smile
and there's something we can all learn
from that now go check out
scp-662 butler's handbell and scp-507
reluctant dimension hopper for more
unusual but harmless humanoid scps